[Music]
I'm definitely not naturally a morning
person but I've kind of trained myself
to be a morning person so every day I
wake up at 7:00 and do workout or yoga
or something just to get my body moving
and that wakes me up but if I didn't
have an alarm
I could literally sleep in till 10:00
every day other than food of course and
maybe that makes me feel so energized
but also meditation so sometimes I'll
just wake up sits on my bed take about
ten minutes just to keep my eyes closed
and think about the day ahead and that
really energizes me for the rest of the
day London can feel really overwhelming
and hectic it's always busy always so
many people but I just find getting
outside and exercising outside if you
can as well really helped my daily
mantra is to wait 24 hours before you
say anything to kind of in the heat of
the moment I feel like you can always
regret things if you just say things
there and then and you can easily upset
people and you say things that you don't
mean so if I feel agitated about
something I always wait 24 hours to
actually sit on it and think about it
before I say it's that person I try not
to look at social media for about an
hour before I go to bed and that really
helps to get a better night's sleep
so I feel like I just don't need
Instagram or Twitter as I'm going to bed
it's so easy to get into that habit of
always checking your phone before you
sleep but you really don't need it
the thing that really keeps me motivated
is actually my audience more than
anything so all of my videos I always go
through and read all of the comments I
didn't have that I kind of feel like
that was my point in doing what I do so
the editing is one point no me glad to
see your breakers giving you inspiration
force amazing content that's really
great when people actually recognize the
hard work they put in I just find it
really really sweet oh and then I saw
this one the other day know me reminds
me of Audrey Hepburn and I replied to
him oh my god that's the best compliment
and thank you so so much really but I'll
take it
it's so hard to predict where I'm going
to be in ten years even like one year I
don't know because every day changes and
that's what's so exciting about my job
that's why I love it it's so
unpredictable in a way but I've seen
myself having a few more books out still
on YouTube still blogging traveling
maybe I'll be living in a different
country who knows that I'm definitely
and going to be still on YouTube
[Music]
[Music]
- working being for about three years
now
so my managers and just help me out here
these won't be able to do what I do
without them and probably here about
twice a week I love just bringing my
laptop here I've set up at one of the
desks and just work all daily editing
videos writing blog posts that kind of
thing I love being in this whole kind of
work environment around other people and
when I come here at the end of the day I
go through things that a subpoena
explained that's what I'm gonna do today
to go through some email I always love
reading people's letters they're always
ready three
but the best part far away's the
packages oh this is so perfect this is a
marble chopping board delicious little
that's so open let's see what this one
is okay this is from a brand called tar
tar cosmetic basically Wow okay they've
sent me so much this is amazing so I've
got quite a big event coming up in a
couple of weeks so it's really kind me a
couple of designers have sent me these
amazing dresses generally I feel more
comfortable in a nice color this one's
gorgeous sorry now I basically have to
decide which one to wear so I think I'm
going to try on a couple and suit you
want to go with I'm kind of both flats
and Hills I wear heels when I'm going to
an event or going out to dinner or
something but then during the day I
always just wear flats like boots or
trainers you can definitely learn style
I don't think you're born of it because
when I look back in on photos of when I
was about 14 15 years old I definitely
didn't have style it's something that
you're kind of inspired by as you get
older I think inspired by different
people and different designers and
everything so you can definitely learn
the most recent thing that I bought were
a pair of cigarette trousers from
Topshop and they were only about 25
pounds and he fits so well so it's like
the best vibe I've got in a while but
after trying on these dresses I think
I've decided what one I'm going to go
for I absolutely loved this red one this
is by outline and I'm just obsessed with
this color
so that's part decided and now I'm going
to go out fill up my friends
oh and don't forget to subscribe to
glamour UK and if you want more of me my
channel is linked in the description box
down below to play
[Music]